aterrizó temprano el jueves email es una
estrella como ninguna otra el Panda
gigante de 28 años de Japón con sus
hijas gemelas los tres mamíferos
servirán de base de investigación para
la cría de pandas gigantes
su regreso a China sigue al de
shang-ching una hembra nacida en Japón
en 2017 Hace unos días miles de fans
japoneses acudieron a despedir a su
ídolo peludo blanco y negro
en ocasiones con gran emoción
no solo es linda sino también
encantadora y divertida es tan atractiva
que si la ves una vez Quieres verla más
aquí hecho amigos con los que comparto
esta pasión
estoy segura de que Shan Chan también
será un ídolo en China y espero que siga
sirviendo a la amistad entre Japón y
China
la diplomacia del Panda es una
iniciativa China para estrechar sus
lazos con países extranjeros según la
ong wwwf organización de protección del
medio ambiente
1860 pandas gigantes viven en libertad
en China
otros 600 viven en cautiverio en centros
para pandas y parques naturales de todo
el mundo